die bayerischen alpen sind ein winter
reiseziel für urlauber jeden alters auf
zahlreichen wegen und läuten können
skilangläufer und wanderer sport und
naturerlebnis verbinden
der kleine ort ruhpolding liegt nahe der
österreichischen grenze und biete
typisch süddeutsche architektur und
atmosphäre
rund 6300 menschen leben hier an den
ausläufern erhalten
vor allem im winter übersteigt gekleidet
uhr ist deutlich die der einwohner
das liegt zum einen am biathlon weltcup
der ihr jedes jahr ausgetragen wird
zudem finden athleten wie skicross profi
thomas fischer vier gute
trainingsmöglichkeiten
das heißt bilder sagen mehr als tausend
worte
und es trifft eigentlich genau gut also
hinter uns wären eigentlich schönen
sommer
wir sind jetzt gott sei dank verschneit
die die pisten hier sind sensationell
man kann hunderte von kilometer hier
laufen und wenn man glück hat trifft man
es aber auch einen profisportler aber
sogar amateure haben hier die
einzigartige gelegenheit wie profis zu
trainieren natürlich mit ausgebildeten
trainer
dies ist der vierte und wenig gelände
durch der ehemalige biathlet fischer
leitet wichtig ist nicht einschüchtern
herkommt was er doch der
sicherheitsbereich losgeht mit dem arzt
sondern sie war völlig immer dort
sicherheit zuerst lautet hier das motto
im nachlauf techniken die fältchen
technik und wenn man nach einer stunde
fertig sind dann hat jeder mal die
chance hier zu schießen und anschließend
in der kleinen weg haben wir mal zu
erleben wie für ein sportlich in dieser
kulisse werden auch wenn so ein schönes
wetter jetzt immer viel sport machen
kann
fischer hat 1992 bei den olympischen
winterspielen in frankreich eine gold
medaille für deutschland geholt vom
aktiven wettkampfsport hat er sich
zurückgezogen
heute arbeitet er als trainer in der
eigenen anlage sein augenmerk liegt auf
den waffen
was ist eine kleinkaliberwaffe 5,6
millimeter was ist die munition sieht
man hier die von vorne in den magazinen
jeweils vom schuss und ist immer ist sie
sicherheitsbereich ist sehr sehr groß
geschrieben bei dem bei den biathlon
erleben wenn man sagt dass diese eine
chance eine scharfe waffe und man muss
immer so weiter vorne sein damit die
mündung freunde über die bekannte steht
die teilnehmer gruppe ist bunt gemischt
vom studenten bis zu handwerkern von
ehemaligen profi sportlern bis zu
geschäft werden reale wollen vor allem
eins spaß im vordergrund
[Applaus]
und dann geht es richtig los
die langläufer müssen eine komplette
runde laufen über toreschießen geht
jeder schütze wird von einem
professionellen trainer begleitet der
darauf achtet dass alle regeln
eingehalten werden
und genau wie beim echten biathlon
geflüsterten fünf daneben bieten in
diesem fall kniebeugen nur nacheinander
dürfen wieder einmal loslegen
jeder muss erst für eine gesamte runde
beendet haben bevor der nächste schlafen
kann leitung training mit voller
ausrüstung kostet 159 euro an gewinnen
am ende die frage gibt es noch eine
erforschung in einer der vielen
abrechneten
[Musik]
diese rücken meistens im traditionellen
blockhaus dies aber aus südlichen im
ganzen tal verstreut
geöffnet sind die während der gesamten
saison
verletzte sich nach einem harten
biathlon training gut entspannen
anstrengend ein wenig aber es hat sehr
viel spaß gemacht wir haben zumindest
nicht alles daneben geschossen
wir haben auch ab und zu getroffen die
berge die christen der sport und das
kalte wetter machen einen winterurlaub
in ruhpolding unvergesslich